wanna be happy build a life not just a
business
hey it's evan carmichael and this
channel was created to help you overcome
the number one challenge that is holding
you back a lack of belief in yourself
you watch these videos because you know
you've got something more inside you do
you have michael jordan level talent at
something so today let's live your best
believe life and learn how we can change
our brain to change our life
enjoy
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one stay conscious with dr joe dispenza
every time we have a thought we make a
chemical and and if you have
an unlimited thought you will feel
unlimited and if you have a
self-depreciating thought you'll feel
unworthy and your brain instantaneously
fires circuits
that signal another part of the brain to
release peptides or chemical messengers
that signal hormonal centers
and when we get that arousal from the
thought that we think
those thoughts sometimes weaken the
response weakens the physical body so
it turns out that
the emotions that are created from the
thoughts are the signaling mechanisms of
the body thoughts of the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body and how we think and how we feel
creates our state of being
so it turns out that the thoughts based
in the stress hormones
based in survival those are the thoughts
that begin to push the genetic buttons
that create disease in other words
a person wakes up in the morning
and the brain is a record of the past
the first thing they do when they wake
up in the morning is they start thinking
about their problems
and those problems are memories that are
etched in the brain that are connected
to certain people certain objects
certain things at certain times and
places so if you believe that your
thoughts have something to do with your
destiny the moment you think about your
problems you're thinking in the past
right
now every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them because
we've experienced them so the moment you
remember your problems
now you feel unhappy now you feel
anxious now you feel fear
so the moment we feel those emotions it
takes a thought and a feeling
a memory or an image an emotion
a stimulus and a response and we start
conditioning the body emotionally into
the past now the body
is so objective
that it doesn't know the difference
between the real life experience that's
creating that emotion
and the emotion that person's
fabricating by thought alone the body's
believing it's in that environmental
condition
so if the environment signals the gene
and that's the truth
and the end product of an experiences in
the environment is an emotion
we're signaling the same genes and genes
make proteins and if you keep signaling
the same genes you start down regulating
the gene to make cheaper proteins and
the body begins to break down now that's
an unconscious process
so what goes along with that is the
moment the person feels that emotion of
unhappiness or whatever it is
the brain checks in with the body and
says yeah you're feeling pretty
miserable you're suffering and we tend
to generate more thoughts
equal to the feeling that we have
and so then we get caught in this loop
of thinking and feeling so if we can't
think
greater than how we feel
our feelings have become the means of
thinking
then we're thinking in the past right
and so we call that
the familiar past and then a person gets
going in the day and they start thinking
oh i gotta see this person i gotta go to
that meeting i hate doing this and now
they get in their routine
and a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists
is the sweet spot of the generous
present moment that is when the body and
mind are free from those conditions so
along with those emotions that influence
the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
then the bodies sing you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you're getting traffic and
you're angry then at 11 o'clock you
check your emails and you're really
judgmental and frustrated the body's
saying well you've been doing this for
the last 20 years you're just going to
stop today so now the body which has
been conditioned emotionally to be the
mind wants to return back to its
familiar territory to the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so that's when the person makes the
same choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling okay i'll complain
just so i can feel suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown to step into
possibility and the hardest part about
that process
first of all is not making the same
choice as you did day before
and here's the payoff
you got to stay conscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so
the thoughts that they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and you're tweeting and you're
instagramming and facebooking whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm going to feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then
if you say then you're not going to live
in the familiar future a familiar past
or predictable future you're not going
to think about how long you've been
meditating what you got to do you you
labor
for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now
that's greater than the program and if
the person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from the body as
energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
they're working and lowering the volume
to that emotion the more they lower the
volume of that emotion the more they're
going to take their attention off that
person and problem and they're going to
take their power back there's going to
be a break
in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else rule number two feel the
goal with john ashraf as you may know i
came from a pretty rough and tough
background in my childhood and i wasn't
used to hanging around with successful
people or being part of the world of the
wealthy
if i hadn't discovered
how to retrain my brain to change my
results chances are i would have ended
up in jail or the morgue
now for me i had a very successful
mentor named alan brown
and allen took it upon himself to show
me
many of the secrets that wealthy people
understood which allowed them to have
what i think is almost a magical ability
to set and achieve goals and it can seem
impossible to achieve those same goals
to people who don't understand how the
process works
and so as part of my training
alan had me do something
i think it's very interesting what he
had me do is he had me write down
one
extremely specific goal
with a date associated with it of when i
would achieve it
but then he asked me to do something
that seemed i guess pretty boring since
i was 19 years old and it seemed
redundant to do it over and over again
but he had me read this goal
every single day
with my fingers scrolling on the words
of the page
he told me
to do my best to feel the words with my
fingers now i know it may sound crazy
but he wanted me to feel the world the
the words and he wanted me to imagine
that what i had written down
was true
and that the goal that i had written
down one goal one date
was becoming a reality for me so he had
me in essence
read
put my fingers across the words and see
myself moving towards those goals and
what he shared with me
is that when you see read and feel this
goal
in this way
you're actually sending an electrical
signal
to your brain from your finger up your
arm to your brain which does what
it makes you much more likely to achieve
this goal
little did he know that what he said
would later be 100 validated by
neuroscientific discoveries
let me explain there is a term in the
brain research the science field that
goes like this
the neurons brain cells that fire
together
wire together
what this means is that when you
activate by hearing seeing running your
finger on your goals
when you activate and wire the different
brain cells together they formulate a
pattern
the more you reinforce that pattern the
more it becomes a strong
automatic pattern in your brain
that causes you to think feel and do
things differently so your reality
changes now on any given day you have 30
40 50 000 thoughts popping up in your
head
some of these thoughts are caused by
internal influences such as your
memories your beliefs
habits that you have
others
are caused by external influences like
texts you receive
facebook cell phones traffic bird flying
across you know the sky
into your window these thoughts cause
your mind and even mind to be scattered
all over the place most of the day with
no clear direction or focus
and so
if you think of your brain
as an organ right
i'm gonna pull my brain from right over
here i've got a brain okay right over
here it's not my brain but it's a brain
if you think of your brain as an organ
that you could put to work for yourself
like a loyal servant
then what you also need to do is you
need to direct it and if you don't it'll
just wander all over the place with no
idea what you actually want
so if your goals are scattered so will
your focus be but as soon as you set a
goal and choose to consistently
and consciously focus on it your brain
realizes that this is important to you
and then what happens is it starts to
automatically notice ways to bring you
things that you want from the
perspective of teaching you how to focus
on it and this is one of the best ways
to activate and create a new pattern in
your
non-conscious brain which you've
probably heard a million times is where
your real power is rule number three
question your thoughts with moran surf
we tend to be really really
skeptical questioning doubtful critical
of people coming from the outside
but we're very trusting of the inside
and the inside is what's actually being
hacked right now
and what people can exploit to get to us
we call it the eminem like a really
really strong shell that keeps things
from the outside but once you get in
it's all chocolate
we trust our brain blindly
and more and more
hackers like myself are showing that we
can actually get into your mind and
change some things there
and when we do that you will never
suspect that
years of evolution have taught us to be
skeptical of the outside world but never
to doubt our own mind if you start
doubting your own thoughts it would be
really really difficult to live normal
life
my students made this t-shirt that i
think helps us
understand how difficult it is it says
don't believe everything you think
and that is maybe the take-home message
for my talk today which is what needs to
be changed is that we need to start
doubting our own mind
let's do a thought experiment in this
room
you're sitting here with me right now
you're in this room tomorrow you meet
your friend and your friend says you
know it was lovely that yesterday we
were together in the library
you say no no yesterday i was listening
to this speaker talking about the brain
i remember the guy says no you were with
me in the library here is a picture of
the two of us in the library
and it shows you a picture of the two of
you
how likely to change your mind to say
you know what
maybe i wasn't listening to a talk in
the morning i was actually in the
library
the reality is that it's very very hard
for you to believe anything if your mind
contradicts that you will think that
you're right
regardless of tons of evidence it comes
to the contrary because we readily
mistrust
our own brain our brain has many many
sites and each site has its own function
and it just knows that it expects some
input and outputs to come and go but it
doesn't really know what other systems
are doing for example
if i ask you right now how much is a two
plus five let's go over all the steps
that happen in your mind for you to get
the answer
first you heard my sound that turned
molecular vibrations in the air into a
concept in your auditory cortex
which you then move to the part of the
brain that does language processing and
there you saw the sentence two plus five
then you had to break it into perceptual
entities so you sent it to a different
system that says okay there's something
called two something called five
something called pass each of them is
its own thing we need to do equation
solving so let's send it to the math
area that's gonna do the crunching and
copy the number seven send it back
another entity is now set there the
number seven which is being sent to the
language area where you make it into a
word seven and then maybe you send it to
the area of the brain that controls the
mouth and tells them how to move to
state that's just a simplification
of all the systems involved in your
brain when you do the solution to the
question how much is two plus five
now the thing is the system in the
center does not do math it just sends
those entities and waits for a number
so if someone sat in the middle
and just saw the communication and send
a different answer you would never know
if instead of the number seven coming up
from the one area you would just get the
number nine you would think this is the
answer you would never doubt your own
mind and in fact now
in the world we have more known people
that have a device an implant in their
brain that can sit in between and do
things for them in the us
there's about 40 000 people right now
that have a cheap insider brain for
clinical purposes
usually for clinical depression or
parkinson's disease and this is supposed
to do only one thing
but the reality is that as soon as you
put something digital in your brain
hackers can come in
and start changing things
so not only do you have the problem of
having to be skeptical of the outside
world now you have to ask yourself do i
trust my own mind
and as time goes by more and more people
from silicon valley mainly come to me as
a scientist and say we want to put a
device inside our brain
and my prediction is at some point it's
going to happen
people are going to want
more brain power they're going to want
to be able to access wikipedia from
their mind
to solve much more complex problems than
how much is two plus five in their mind
to maybe speak more languages
intuitively to have better memory
to do high frequency trading
as soon as we see the benefit for that
people are gonna want more and more of
that and as you have a chip inside your
brain the sky the limit to what hackers
can do
to get in and change stuff
so
what are we going to do about that
well
the good news is that hackers also gave
us some solutions
hackers know something that i think
would be important for you to know which
is that there is a way to fight
hacking into a system
and that is
to doubt the integrity of the security
you can put all the firewalls all the
antiviruses everything to secure things
from the outside but in the end what
hackers would tell you is that the best
way to defend something
is to say
let's imagine for a second that someone
is already in my system it's only
already hacked into my system what will
i do then imagine if someone is already
hacked into your emails what would you
do
maybe you will change your password
right away maybe when you start looking
at your emails you will say is that
something that really could come from
who it said it is or maybe i should
doubt it and i call and say hey did you
send me this thing
you know
a few days ago was a april 1st which is
also known as april fool
and i was traveling with two of my
friends and i tried to prank them when i
feel full i told them something and as
soon as i started my prank the first guy
said wait it sounds very suspicious and
today is april 1st i'm gonna listen to
you with some criticism
and in many ways this is what we should
do we should always say
do i actually believe my own thoughts
because in a world
where someone connecting to our brain
we would have a hard time even knowing
if what we think we are is true and the
entire premise of the world right now
relies on you trusting yourself we have
people going to the voting ballot and in
the end they close the curtain and say
now it's only me now i can listen to my
own gut and know what i want and i'm
going to look and dive deep into my
personality and decide if i vote
democrats are republican and i know and
we have senators like the voter always
knows or the customer is always right
or beauty is in the eye of the beholder
or seeing is believing and all of them
assume one thing which is when it goes
into your mind
you can trust it
so solutions
first doubt
always true
didn't change
now
another one
surround yourself with people
that can verify your reality ask
question do you think that something i
would say more so put yourself next to
people that have opposite opinions
this is really helpful and in fact a
really good game to play
is to say
you know i always was a democrat all my
life i'm about to vote democrats i want
to stop for a second and ask the
question what would need to happen for
me to convince myself to vote the
opposite republicans
the same way i told you in the beginning
to ask yourself what needs to happen for
you to convince yourself that you are
not here with me
if you live in a world where you say
everyone can hack into everything and i
can't trust my own mind
a good idea is to play a game where
every now and then you say let's doubt
everything in my mind and try to create
a new world rule number four be aware of
your habits with james clear there are a
couple ways to think about it but i
would say just quick definition a habit
is a behavior that has been repeated
enough times to be performed more or
less automatically
so you can do it pretty much on
autopilot but another way to think about
it i think this is a useful way to
define a habit is that
as you go through life you face
different problems and some of those
problems are big and some of them are
small like you need to tie your shoes
and whenever you face a problem your
brain starts looking for solutions to
that and as you come across solutions to
the recurring problems in life
you start to automate those and so every
morning you wake up and you put your
shoes on and you've got this little
problem that you need to solve and
pretty soon after you tie your shoes 100
times or 500 times or a thousand times
you can do it pretty much without
thinking
and so that's another way of thinking
about habits is that they're kind of
these like automatic solutions we fall
into for whatever the recurring problems
are we face right behavior that becomes
habituated yeah and you know like there
the interesting thing about this is you
don't necessarily
have to have the same habit to solve a
recurring problem like if you come home
from work each day and you feel stressed
and exhausted one person might
play video games for an hour and that's
a way to resolve that problem so they
get in the habit of doing it they just
walk over the controller they don't
think about it another person might go
for a run for 20 minutes or meditate for
10 minutes third person might smoke a
cigarette and all of those are just
solutions to that problem that you're
facing and
that i think is another powerful lesson
is that your original habit is not
necessarily the optimal one and once you
realize that then it kind of becomes
your responsibility to
become a little more aware of what those
habits are and then think about can you
shape them or design them right also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video i've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned in this video as
well as pull out our three favorite
learnings and quotes that will inspire
you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five take care of your
brain with dr daniel amen so d
is diabetes
and your weight's fine but 70 of the
population
is overweight or obese and i published
two studies that show as your weight
goes up the size and function of your
brain goes down
which should scare the fat off anyway
yeah yeah right and it's why i lost 30
pounds when i figured that connection
out
and i'd always had trouble because i
have fat genes i have a brother and a
sister they're both 150 pounds
overweight and i'm not why because i
don't give in to the behaviors making it
likely to be so and when i figured out
that connection i will never
purposefully do something to shrink my
brain brain health is really three
things it's brain envy you got to care
about it avoid things that hurt your
brain and do things that help it and
they're all equally
important because you don't do the right
thing because you should because nobody
will do that you do the right thing
because you love yourself you love
your wife you love your
kids you love your mission you love your
money whatever it is you love that's why
you want a good brain
and then avoiding and our society is not
helping us in my new book the end of
mental illness that's coming out next
year
there's a fun
writing device where i say if i was an
evil ruler yeah and i wanted to create
mental illness how would i do that and i
basically create american society where
kids are addicted to gadgets
happy meals they're just not happy they
promote illness
when you look at you know what's ever on
a kid's menu it's generally something
that'll hurt them
the increased use of sodas and orange
juice and people go juice why are you
picking on juice because it's unwrapped
fruit sugar that turns toxic in your
body then if you look at water pollution
and air pollution and news pollution
all of those things are perpetuating
mental illness and now we've legalized
marijuana for virtually anything you
want and i'm a fan of legalizing it but
it's not good for you
i mean alcohol is legal is alcohol good
no it's terrible it increases your risk
of seven different kinds of cancer and
people who drink every day have smaller
brains and when it comes to your brain
i'm just sorry size matters it's the
only organ in your body where size
matters and that's your brain
um and so
i published two studies one on a
thousand pot smokers every area of their
brain was lower wow
i'm not a fan rule number six avoid
caffeine close to bedtime with matthew
walker caffeine if you look at some data
is probably the second most traded
commodity on the surface of the planet
after oil which i think says everything
about our sleep-deprived state
the other thing about caffeine however
that most people don't realize
is the time that it is in your system
so
most drugs have what we call a half-life
the amount of time it takes for half of
that drug to be essentially excreted out
your system
caffeine has a half-life of about six or
seven hours and it's a little dependent
on what type of gene that you have to
sort of metabolize the caffeine but on
average it's about that
but what's interesting is that caffeine
has a quarter life of about 12 hours
what this means is that if you have a
cup of coffee at noon
a quarter of that caffeine is still
circulating around your brain at
midnight
so to put that in context it would be
the equivalent of
getting into bed and just before you
turn the light out you swing a quarter
of a cup of starved books and you hope
for a good night of sleep it you know
you would never do that because you know
but that's exactly unfortunately what
people do you know um completely
innocently by drinking caffeine you know
still too late in the afternoon yeah
it's a huge problem it it's it's a i
think it's a big problem in society if
you i mean another way to quantify this
is if you just look and i've checked out
the data from the financial times the
number of starbucks coffee houses that
have arisen
over the past 30 years is just like an
exponential increase and i think that is
an expression of how we're
self-medicating our state of sleep
deprivation in developed nations there
was an alarming study that was done
where they gave people just one single
cup of coffee a dose of 200 milligrams
of caffeine standard cup of coffee
and then they measured the quality of
their deep sleep by tracking these big
powerful brain waves these glorious
beautiful deep brain waves that bathe
all of our brain during deep sleep at
night and it helps also restore the body
and what they found was that just one
dose of caffeine in the evening
decreased the amount of deep sleep by 20
percent
now you would have to normally age by
about 15 years to produce that type of a
deficit in your deep sleep or you can do
it every single night by having a cup of
coffee and what's interesting is that
those people will wake up the next
morning they won't remember waking up
because they may not have woken up but
the quality of their deep sleep was so
poor that they will still then feel
unrestored and unrefreshed by their
sleep i need more caffeine and and so
here is the irony that now they're
starting to reach for two cups of coffee
rather than one and so develops this
dependency cycle this sort of addiction
spiral as it were so i think people are
perhaps unaware of the the true impact
of caffeine how long it sticks around
within your system and even if you feel
that you're immune to that evening cup
of coffee how it will still impact your
sleep even though consciously you know
nothing about it rule number seven don't
get stuck with andrew huberman why are
children such great passive learners
they're not trying they're just learning
they're coming home with all sorts of
things sometimes things you don't want
them to come home with
right it's because they have this
element of play and what is play play
isn't just movement although it includes
movement it's giving things everything
you've got but keeping it in perspective
it's that sweet spot of enjoying life
and trying really really hard at it at
the same time it's essentially what we
all
strive for and there are these
incredible cases throughout history
famous scientists because i grew up in a
house where people you know revered
scientists like like richard feynman
nobel prize winner he's most famous for
bongo drumming naked on the roof of
caltech and he became an amazing artist
in his 60s and he developed all sorts of
other skills he always had this
childlike way of looking at the world he
never let himself get stuck in his ways
never became a curmudgeon and a
remarkable man and that's something that
i if you come away with nothing else i
encourage you to do that you want your
brain to change stay light stay loose
but give it everything you've got rule
number eight learn to be conscious with
nicole lapera anytime we see ourself
repetitive okay right that especially in
situations i know we all can identify
those where whatever we're doing in that
repetitive fashion isn't translating to
the results that we want right if each
time this this this conversation comes
up and you know i react in in one
particular way and i get this
reaction or repercussion if you will and
that doesn't work for me yet i can't
stop
that's usually an indicator that we're
kind of stuck in in that autopilot so
for me it wasn't an aha light bulb
moment for me it was very gradual it was
beginning to use different tools so for
me it was simply realizing how
unconscious i was oh consciousness great
okay so i've learned what i first
learned what does it mean to be
conscious okay being conscious means
being fully present being in a moment
having my senses activate it okay first
question ask myself
how how often are you in that state
during your day and my first answer was
i'm not so now i know i don't really
know what consciousness is like so until
i begin to practice that new habit
and settle into now a more conscious
life now by contrast i can understand
consciousness
versus unconsciousness so a lot of us
have to begin to action i guess is the
way i want to simply answer this
to
break those habits to give ourselves new
lived experiences to be able to
understand right which was that remnant
of the past and which is the future that
i choose to walk toward
listeners who don't you know yet know
kind of how conscious or unconscious
they are throughout their day we all
walk around with cell phones
best suggestion just set an alarm on
your phone for random times throughout
your day so you might not even
remember by the time the alarm goes off
when that alarm goes off and you oh my
alarm's going off
first ask yourself where was my
attention where's my attention right now
that you know i hear this thing and now
i might zap back in to the current
moment where was it was i worrying about
the argument that i had with my partner
in the morning was i maybe worrying
about what's happening tomorrow
was i like me somewhere somewhere else
but i don't really know where i was
and then when i do identify that i was
somewhere else as a lot of us will
using your senses doing exactly like you
said they can be incredibly what we call
grounding because when i'm activating my
senses i've now removed my attention
from wherever else it was and i brought
it back into my physical body entering
the present moment activating
the prefrontal cortex and actually
different part of our brain from that
subconscious that was probably calling
the shots until you tuned in
firing that up we know that neurons that
fire together wire together right so
we're almost giving ourselves some
mental training and then making it
easier to access that conscious state in
the future so yeah using your senses ask
yourself i'm touching a nice
pillow right here right i'm touching i'm
smelling i'm feeling and now i'm
conscious a lot of us probably will
shift right out of that consciousness
very quickly if we're used to
being in that unconscious autopilot
which is why i say it's a practice we
have to over time gradually every chance
we can make that choice when we notice
oh i'm somewhere else to come back here
i know that every time you're doing that
you're helping your brain to make that
your
more easy to access state rule number
nine be intentional with jim quick we
are bombarded with an avalanche of
information right each and every day and
it is overwhelming right and you must
intend to remember something if you are
going to remember something it's as
simple as that if you forgot a name now
by the way say yes if this is you uh
have you forgotten a name recently
have you forgotten where you parked your
car have you misplaced things that you
use every single day like you're the
remote control or maybe your phone
have you ever lost your train of thought
have you ever forgot what someone just
said
like maybe something i just said right
and uh there's a quote from my mentor
his name is dr steven covey many of you
have read his book
seven habits highly affected people he
said most people do not listen with the
intention to understand most people
listen with the intention to
reply so they're not really
understanding because their their
intention is they're not they're
thinking about how they're going to
respond and one of his habits was seek
first to understand then to be
understood because people don't care how
much you know until they know how much
you care
and that's why your intention matters
people could feel your intention now how
are we defining intention
well in in latin uh intent just is uh is
your aim it is uh it is your purpose
right it can be defined as a thing that
you intended an aim a plan the power of
intention is is really the power of a
focused dedicated mind and intention is
a great starting point you know it's a
starting point for every goal having the
intention of every dream that you have
it is the creative power that fulfills
in our needs you know whether it happens
to be love or in relationships health
money or wealth right think about it
everything happens
in life began with an intention some
kind of intention when you decided to
buy that gift when you if you decide to
wiggle your fingers if you decide to
text a friend
if you want to remember someone's name
it all starts with the intention of
doing so
right wayne dyer says our intention
creates our reality think about that our
intention
creates our reality
right
i uh i know oprah has mentioned talk the
power of intention also as well that
intention is he says attention is one
with cause and effect and so intention
it determines our our outcome right and
she mentions in one of her quotes that
if you're stuck moving forward you have
to check the thought and the action that
has created your your circumstances so
that's the power of intention and so
how do we
learn how do we live less out of habit
and more through intention and let's
just think about that when you're
focusing your mental energy on something
that
let's say we're able to give more of our
brain power to it it's not
magic at all because there's a method
behind the magic you know it's our
innate
tool that we have this is the power of
the mind being placed in a position
where you are planning where you are
preparing where you need to be able to
perform at
optimal levels right
and so intention isn't a do it once and
and forget about it
it's not that kind of thing it's this
continuous consistent use of the mind in
a focused manner and when you cultivate
this state and use it you can get what
you want in life easier when we're
thinking about cultivating the state of
intention there there are three clear
steps right so you could write this down
or you probably easily remember this
number one is you have to decide what
you want and that's in your head right
you have to decide what you want uh this
now
by the way when you're
by definition the power of intention you
need to know
what your goal is right when you're
thinking about intention
the aim
you know is
the goal
the dream so you set that intention
if you don't know this you're never
going to be able to utilize your power
because clarity gives you power
right the very easy phrase to remember
is i commit myself to this i
commit
myself to
remembering people's names i commit
myself to a memory where i parked the
car that could be your intention most
people just par they're mindless right
they park their car or they go on
autopilot they're not thinking about
things or they're at home and you put
something somewhere but they're inten
there's no
intention behind
uh remembering where that thing is right
because they're not mindful and i'm
going to do a specific episode on
mindfulness so the first step is
get in your head right what do you want
and what do you want with clarity and so
what's your intention around learning
and your intention around life right the
second thing i would say is from head
you go into your heart all right this
this is really your your why you have to
get clear on your why
you know
now that you know what you want why why
do you want it
you know what is it going to give you
because reasons reap results reasons
reap results and honestly
reasons reap rewards also as well
because a lot of people know what to do
here in their head but they don't do it
with their hands which is the third part
because they're not connected with their
heart the emotions the energy of motion
right so you set the intention in your
head
right you feel it in your heart in terms
of why you must do it right simon sinek
has a great book called star with why
and then finally the third stage really
is your hands head hard hands and that's
where you work for it right once you
know what you want and why you want it
that serves as a great foundation it's
very attractive you know but you can't
have the law of attraction without the
law of action right even you can see the
word action in the word attraction right
so you can't even make up you can't even
make the word attraction without the
word action literally the last six
letters of attraction is the word what
action right and so that gets to your
hands and so what is your intention in
your head and then feel the intention in
your heart in terms of why you want it
and then be very intentional
with your hands meaning the method
you're going to take place right because
your intention it's a it's a it's almost
a guiding principle of how you want to
be on how you want to learn on how you
want to live on how you want to show up
in the world and rule number 10 the last
one before some very special bonus clips
is get
started with mel robbins activation
energy is something that was first
introduced into the field of human
behavior and psychology several decades
ago by a rock star professor at the
university of chicago that studied a
state of flow his name was mihai chiksen
mihai and he studied was one of the
first really to study human behavior
human performance and he coined this
term activation energy actually borrowed
it from chemistry and it's a term that
describes this phenomenon in order to
start
any kind of chemical reaction it takes a
tremendous amount of energy to create
that initial spark
a lot more energy to start it than to
keep it going
there's a direct correlation to you and
me have you ever noticed how hard it is
to just get started how hard it is to
get to the gym how hard it is to get out
of bed how hard it is to put down
the bottle when you go to pour a second
drink and you know you shouldn't
that feeling how hard it is to get
started
this is what mihai's talking about
you need activation energy to start the
chain
to start to sit down to start to get out
of bed to start to walk out the door
that's the key to creating any kind of
change this activation energy inside of
you that causes the initial
boom
and then what do we hear over time once
you start there's a chain reaction and
that allows you to keep going
so what's this have to do with the five
second rule freaking everything the
five-second rule
creates
activation energy in you the five-second
rule is how you activate change inside
of you it is a tool when you start
counting five four three two one
you awaken your prefrontal cortex you
begin the process of changing you push
yourself in a new direction that first
push that's going to be the hardest
once you get moving it gets so much
easier now i've got a special bonus clip
that i think you're going to enjoy but
before that it's time for the good deed
of the day this is something new i
believe that you're able to serve and it
feels so good to do something nice for
somebody else so good deed of the day
put down in the comments one thing that
you need help with that you're working
on you'd love some support or guidance
on and then two go
comment on somebody else's comment and
give them some love give them some
support give them some encouragement
maybe give them some connections try to
help them solve that problem even if
it's saying i believe in you that one
little bit of encouragement can be the
difference between somebody quitting and
continuing on so the good deed of the
day in the comments below write down one
thing that you need help on that you're
struggling with that you're working on
and then part two is go give love to
somebody else in the comments too and
let them know that you believe in them
as well you're never gonna accomplish
anything great if you're coming from a
place of negativity if you are just
complaining and negative and blaming
other people you're never going to
accomplish anything it's just not going
to happen you can't create amazing
things from a negative spot
it means that you have zero
resourcefulness because there's no hope
and so you need to flip it now i'm going
to give you a wild mind trick that that
i use that maybe is a little too weird
duck for you but i want to test it on
you because if if one of you picks it up
it'll dramatically change your life it's
my philosophy of changing negative
situations and doing a quick mind trick
in my head to say it's the best
so whenever i'm hit with a negative
situation something that is beyond my
control something that i can't do
anything about i will complain i will be
unhappy i'll be negative for eight to 24
seconds
and then i'll tell myself
it's the best that this is the best
thing that happened to me and then i'll
figure out why it's the best so as an
example i'm on an airplane i'm coming
from vancouver to l.a i'm speaking at an
event in l.a i'm on a flight it's a five
hour flight i get on this is really
smelly dude next to me really smelly guy
he probably hadn't been on you know in a
shower in a couple days probably had
multiple transfers and stopovers and i
have empathy i'm not i'm not pissed at
him i'm pissed at the situation right
i'm sure he's normally a nice smelling
guy and takes care of himself but in
this situation
he was super smelly and i had to deal
with it so what am i gonna do i got a
five hour flight what are my options i
can
not go
you know i could miss my flight and then
not do my presentation i could sit on
the airplane and be upset for the next
five hours and then be upset for the
rest of the day and allow this minor
situation to own me and to be better
than me and ruin my entire day or i
could say this is the best
and that's what i did for around eight
to 24 seconds i'm sitting there trying
to figure out
my options what options do i have how
can i do how can i fix this
there's no options i'm screwed and then
i'm upset you know i'm upset this sucks
come on really this is what i have to
deal with the next five hours and then
this is the best
and what do i do
[Music]
yep
breathe it in breathe it in give it to
me because this is making me stronger
this is the best this is actually the
best why because it's my chance to show
myself what i'm made of that this smelly
dude is not going to own me that i am
stronger than a little bit of smell on
an airplane and that the next time i get
faced with a similar situation i'm able
to handle it it's easy it rubs off me i
think that's how you actually build
self-confidence that's how you actually
build self-esteem because when it's easy
it's easy winning a race against
three-year-olds is easy doesn't mean
anything you're not going to clap that
up yeah i beat a bunch of
three-year-olds but when it's hard and
you try
that's when you actually build
self-esteem
and so flip it flip it in your mind flip
it this is the best whatever negative
situation is in front of you right now
tell yourself it's the best let me give
you another example i'm on a keto diet
six days a week saturdays eat what i
want and sunday to friday i'm on a keto
diet eating super healthy you know all
avocados and vegetables and some fish
and
we're traveling right now and i'm doing
a 90-day tour across the country and i
told myself i want to come back
in better shape in lower weight than
when i left it's easy for me to stay
consistent at home but when i travel
it's always been my vice when i travel
for a couple days i'll just veg out eat
whatever i want frappuccinos down and
everything it's like yeah
sugar i can't do that for 90 days
because i come back a giant tub so i
needed to say okay you know what here's
a challenge this is my chance to prove
myself this is my chance to show myself
what i'm made of i want to come back
weighing less than when i left and so
we're visiting all these cities and
there's tons of great food in every city
right and and i want to look at the food
and i want to smell it
i want it i want to look at it
and i'm stronger than you every grocery
store that we go into i love going down
the sugar aisle i love going down the
snack eye i love seeing the klondike
reese's pieces bars i love seeing the
doritos i love seeing them and i love
smelling them whenever i can and just
knowing that i'm stronger i think if you
eliminate the junk food from your house
and you're on a diet it actually makes
you weaker you're training yourself that
you're not capable of resisting and so
there's junk all over the place here
yeah let me show you look here we go
look we just finished off some junk but
we got right here right here on the
kitchen counter we've got
fudge and more fudge and then
whatever those things are pineapples and
then some some fudge sea salt
caramels just lying out
right in here we got doritos we got look
at this this is going to kill me look
this is your peppermint patties you
kidding me i want to get that entire bag
right now what else
let's go to the third drawer look at
this we got we got sticker bites we got
i'm gonna i could eat this entire bag
right now i'm so hungry we got
we got raisins right chocolate covered
raisins are you kidding me this stuff is
amazing i can't wait i want to eat all
of it and here's what i do when they
come home look at this this one here
this dark chocolate
can you help me open this because i'm
filming
[Music]
danny
danny
so here's the thing here's what i would
love if i wanted to eat this here's what
i would do here's what i would do i
would open it up like this
and just smell it just smell it and know
that i'm stronger than these sea salt
caramels now this actually pisses me off
because
i don't like dark chocolate i can't
stand the smell
and so it smells nasty to me but
i wanted to smell good i wanted to smell
good i want to smell i wanted to be
right here on top of the counter in
front of my face
right doritos i want it right in front
of my face i have a giant bag of doritos
at my home in my office because readers
are my weakness
because damn the doritos
because the doritos aren't stronger than
me
right that smelly guy on the airplane
he's not stronger than me i'm capable of
doing that i'm capable of doing more and
so i love that and maybe that's a little
crazy and when i tell people that story
they say well doesn't that deplete your
your willpower because you only have a
certain amount of willpower for the day
and if you force yourself through that
you're going to deplete your willpower
and then other decisions become more
difficult and
i get it logically but for me
maybe it's just the mind trick coming to
play because that makes me stronger
i want more of it i love myself more
because of that i love it it gives me
more energy doesn't take away my
willpower it creates more willpower for
myself and i can't wait to dive into all
that stuff on a saturday but when when
nina and danny are coming back with all
this food i want to smell it i want to
look i want to love it i want my mouth
to water even just thinking about the
doritos right now my mouth is watering
so much and i love so much about myself
that i'm not diving into it and so
changing your identity
that i'm the kind of person who rises to
a challenge who when it's difficult i
crush it i jump into it i love it i
think when you can do that you're much
more likely to go off and accomplish
your goals i think when you do that
you're much more able to handle
adversity in your life and just that
quick mindset shift just that quick
trick into your brain every single time
you find yourself being negative being
complaining being upset tell yourself
it's the best this is my chance to show
myself and the world
what i'm made of let's go bring me your
doritos bring me your smelly man i got
this i'm ready
you're ready too it's the best
yes you have access to a hundred percent
of your brain all of the time
but does that mean that we actually use
the whole brain all of the time and the
answer is no
because what we start to find out is
when we start to live in patterns and in
habits that what happens is we just
activate certain neuronal pathways that
are habitual pathways and as a result
these are the pathways that have
preference in our everyday life
but if you can engage whole brain
activity you can enhance your
consciousness and your awareness and
your ability to control your life so
basically says that we can become whole
brain when we start to think
holistically instead of just playing
recurrent programs that play over and
over again and activate the same
pathways
so the relevance is that once we start
to engage in whole brain activity we
enhance our ability as humans on this
planet and now we're beginning to find
out there are many different ways to
engage and activate the whole brain
some of them involve simple exercises
such as something called brain gym and
brain gym is a very interesting exercise
of the body and the nervous system
integration in this way
my right hand is controlled by my left
hemisphere
my left hand is controlled by my right
hemisphere but here's an interesting
story if my right hand controlled by my
left hemisphere crosses the midline
then it simultaneously gets picked up by
the other hemisphere because now it's in
that territory as well so when you cross
your arms and when you cross your legs
what you're doing is causing the right
and the left hemispheres to work
together in harmony
when we are activating brain
synchronization where right and left
hemispheres are engaged together
simultaneously
it activates something like super
learning with both hemispheres working
together we have much more superior
characteristics of neural function
however after age seven and eight
we start to express what is called brain
dominance meaning during the day we
don't have synchronization of both
hemispheres during the day it's like a
wave form sometimes we're more in the
left hemisphere sometimes we're more in
the right then it comes back to the left
and back to the right so that we're
cycling through one hemisphere at a time
this is called brain dominance where one
hemisphere is dominant over the other
hemisphere well the relevance about that
is integrating our lives is very
difficult in brain dominance for simple
reason
as been suggested our left hemisphere is
based on logic and details
our right hemisphere is actually
associated with emotions and wholeness
and this becomes very important because
if you're only looking with your left
hemisphere then all the logic things
make sense but there's no emotional
component to it
and reverse if you're in the right
hemisphere you get emotionally tied up
but the logic drops out
well this happens to us ever since the
time we were eight through our adult
life if you can get both hemispheres to
be in sync hemisync
then you're engaging logic and emotions
at the same time that opens up a window
for super learning opportunities where
you can download information very very
quickly very fast but it also opens up a
whole wide range of thinking that
includes an emotional component as well
as an intellectual component which is
necessary to fulfill a whole picture so
if you're operating from brain dominance
you're actually shutting off one
component of your nervous system at that
time
so if you do an exercise like brain gym
where you're involved with crossing your
arms and your legs
when you do that you start to integrate
both very interestingly when we have
hemisync we're much more calm collected
and able to really
express neurological functions that are
very fully supporting of ourselves
and this is why it's very interesting
when you go home and relax at night
sometimes you find yourself with your
ankles crossed over each other just
sitting in your chair without even
knowing what you're doing by crossing
your ankles you're actually engaging a
whole brain process so if you're
stressed for example during the day or
you just want to relax when you go home
at night crossing your arms and legs
actually engages both hemispheres which
calms the system down but engages a
whole brain process so you become much
more effective in your relaxed state so
if you're having a tough moment during
the day just take a moment and cross
your arms and legs hold them together
and just wait for about three or four
minutes and you'll start to feel a
calmness overcome and in this calmness
your neurological functions will be
totally enhanced when we start to
operate from patterns that are replayed
every day we start to express very
specific pathways that are reused over
and over and over again and as a result
we actually shut down a large amount of
functioning of the brain and just go
through the habit the patterns that
replay themselves over and over again
so basically what you really have to
understand is this we can use 100 of the
brain but if we play the same patterns
over and over again we don't need to use
100 of the brain
so um simple point i'd just like to
suggest that once you start to recognize
that you can have hemisink where you can
get right in left hemispheres to engage
together and stay conscious you are
using 100 of your brain activity and
when you do that you'll also find that
your life is easier more harmonious and
healthier because when you're using your
full nervous system it will support your
life and enhance your growth
and this becomes important so don't get
stuck that i'm only using ten percent of
my brain that story is false
you can use a hundred percent
and it's available to us
and basically all you have to understand
is this stay conscious stay mindful and
stop playing the same patterns over and
over again because that opens up an
opportunity to create new behavior when
you stop playing the programs food
what we eat
and
meditative breathing i think are the
most
graspable
and measurable the creativity stuff the
sleep stuff
uh the exercise stuff is harder for
people
uh but the exercise stuff is in its own
way the most important if we can get
back to that ooh why keeps your brain
arteries open releases all these
neurotrophic factors inside your brain
so not just the plumbing that irrigates
the flesh of the brain tell me about but
ignf yeah they're nerve growth factors
they're all neurotrophic factors and
whatever the
the for the in this case to be
abbreviation gdnf bdnf ngf it doesn't
matter they end with gf
and growth factors so it really is i've
heard your word miracle grow but getting
back to the garden analogy
uh to keep the flesh
we're going to get you know electricity
is one thing
to keep the flesh healthy
you have to irrigate it
and that has to do with your brain
arteries
and
since we already said it's not a it's
not a ball
you know it's these uh you know these
jellyfish and they're moving and they're
throbbing and they're pulsating and
their tentacles are reaching out there's
a lot of space in between
and that extracellular space outside of
the actual cells outside the neurons
outside the jellyfish if you will
it's not just water
there's chemicals floating around in
there now dopamine might be just from
technical to technical
you know serotonin might be this way but
what's it what's in all the stuff around
all those billions and billions of
neurons
they're growth factors
and minerals
and chemicals that the brain naturally
has but there's also a soup that these
billions and billions of neurons are
floating in bdnf is a key component of
that soup that helps regulate the health
of each of those uh jellyfish or nerve
and we can trigger more of that exercise
yeah you exercise it releases it it
showers itself it's not like the thighs
thigh muscle sends it up to the brain
the brain says hey i'm feeling good this
is good i like this
i'm gonna create a new rut i'm gonna
remind you you feel good when you run
the brain will shower itself with growth
factors there are growth factors brain
says hey you know the electrochemical
balance is better with those so i think
that's where you get the runners high
it's not just adrenaline it's not
dope it means a happy chemical i'm
jacked up i'm on adrenaline it's just
such a complex ecosystem
and rather than feeling uh
intimidated by that to me i just see
opportunities
on how people can you know improve their
lives
[Music]
if you want to learn to hack your brain
for greater performance and success
check the video right there next to me i
think you'll like it continue to believe
and i'll see you there the diversity of
thinking and the depth of thinking just
one level past what you're used to is
the way to keep the whole garden
flourishing if you're not being defined
by a vision of the future